well apparently in the medicine
community negative means good yeah that
was amazing
yeah I tested very positive pause that
wasn't in big show that she's never got
into you I'd never given myself the
chance oh my what's wrong so big and I
never got it I go against the grain I've
never gotten into it she in the sign
field no I liked other shows that were
fun it like in the friend no I thought
Frasier was really funny
Fraser's awesome really funny I watched
Seinfeld in France but I thought Frasier
was really fun that was my favorite like
sitcom of that time and like I watched
most things that people watch i watch
Ozark I think it's good I don't think
it's the greatest thing everybody like
goes only like better surprise I mean
all of that the wires Sopranos Breaking
Bad I mean a succession is better than
those are Game of Thrones I mean it is
Game of Thrones is watch succession my
phone's watching say you have you ever
wanted that on HBO what's a great it's
about like a family of ultra wealthy
people that owned a TV station it's
great let's done school it's really cool
I started watching narcos Mexican Arcos
the first season was amazing second
season makes you starts blank air starts
you look about the character it's like
wait a minute the real story the
Hispanics sell drugs yes that's a joke
and a lot of that is because we
colonized and did all the wrong things
but yeah that's just that's that's if
you know the history of it like the more
I read in the actual history of it then
I'm into it more on the second season of
Mexico's - the third season they should
do like Norco in America do something to
have white people be the problem you
know what I mean whoa do narcos Alaska
do narcos help Hells Angels yeah some
like that you know no yeah so the very I
don't know I'm trying to do real one you
know Zork is good it's a watchable show
the kid on Ozark his fans of a lot of
podcasts which is good you know the good
the real white should now not the young
kids white trash the white trash kid
who's let's the old lady foxy old lady
he's a fan of Pancho huge fan of all of
the pod Cal a kid Charlie that kid that
kid he does a lot of work
he's like a massive fan of podcast hmm I
don't want to get him in trouble he
looks like a podcasting yeah I mean he
looks like a guy like podcast yeah
does I mean he's good actor really good
actor he plays the same kind of part all
the time but she's like what he looks
like you apply yes yeah he always our
top 5 now it's shocking one last time
you watch the premise amazing I know you
episode here knows our case lock-out
overseen Sopranos I'll explain you what
tells me to watch it could never happen
and it's stupid it's from happy it could
not having mom Missouri on a boat where
a drug dealers selling heroin on a boat
cuz a bunch of other people know a
casino but its sake you're like yeah
whatever it's like none of it could ever
have it's stupid you're right and maven
and Laura Linney are amazing Julia
Garner's amazing amazing that's where
the show so good because the actors sell
it but you're like dude this could never
[ __ ] happen you watch Game of Thrones
and think it could really happen
no but Game of Thrones is also not at
the level of like the wire to Sopranos
like that dude you and I are off I think
Game of Thrones better than all those
like why are all the seasons how many
season six why you're in totality is I
ready show having made once you get into
town one through three no it's also good
the other ones alright in totality
because it took an issue and then showed
it from every different perspective it
was like this brilliant thing that had
never been really done in TV the way it
had been done what it's like you're
looking at it from the cops the dealer
is the press the politicians agree it's
crazy it's to do that with televisions
wild right green so that's why people
put so much weight on Sopranos because
like we've never seen like someone so
vulnerable no it's amazing here out
Breaking Bad all that's like now that
we're in 2020 do you need a season for
Ozark let's be honest I'll do I ever do
you really I don't I don't know where
they're gonna go you said laundry money
hood stuffing money in their breasts no
no but I heard that was good bloodline
is good on Netflix but it's slow but
it's good and it's got some great actors
in it watch an amazing the night hunters
on the Amazon knows that good great do
bloodline is good juice in the Florida
Keys Oh anything floral amah besides
really I'm out yeah I'm starting to the
Florida movement
what is wrong with you I like alligators
but other than that I'm just out of look
at that look at that there's something
afoot some better good curb is it I can
Arby's great curbs on me what you can't
believe I don't love those are yes dude
it's fine it's not bad I respect it what
about documentaries I love documentaries
well did you were you a tiger King fan
great when your favorites I loved it
top five docs ever ah see I disagree
okay give me back I know it was so good
because we're in quarantine it was so
outlandish but if you could go back and
watch it is it better than like you know
why can't a murderer it's better than
the OJ Simpson no no no you're wrong
you're right you're right is it bad and
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] with cats along it got a
little long little cats to people I know
but it took too long that Facebook group
did I should happen in an episode I was
about to kill some of those losers
stalking this poor guy who gives a [ __ ]
yeah don't hurt cats but also who has a
job here ah dude how could I like the
one guy the guy who actually found him I
don't know what he does for a job he
goes I felt like you is a game of cat
and mouse and I got you know what you're
on yeah
six years later Your Honor I've got
nothing to do this let's go do they show
me that he's in LA they show me that la
[ __ ] coffee shop just [ __ ] track
in the dude it shows that everybody just
wants a community yes everybody just
wants a community whether you're hunting
a cat killer or whatever it is you're
just you're but I like Tiger king
because there's one of the only things I
didn't know like I don't not want the
only things I don't know about but like
I don't know anything about like those
shitty zoos and I always wondered about
it when I would drive through these
areas I'd be like you know what is that
a zoo
I'm like what the hell's going on there
like you go through the Everglades in
Florida and you believe somebody what is
this thing but also kind of took you to
that world that interesting why yeah but
there's also this is what happens when a
guy who's addicted to meth gets a bunch
of tigers it's like meth Tigers but he's
the hero of it like he's the hero that
holds the heroes he's the hero you
no worries and what's her name Karen
what's her narrow Herald no no bad
Harold she had her husband killed and
she got away with it he this is a poor
guy who's like yeah C's in math had yes
he's tricked these guys into sleep he
also killed a lot of tigers ever but a
straight guy that that came from
Oklahoma was like didn't ever see Tigers
every podcast have all of these people
on by the way I don't think so we didn't
yeah but a lot of them dead and they all
kill Tigers I interviewed one of the
Tigers oh you did we did a video ad
stager he was an anti-semite
so he had to leave by this sense it's I
think that podcasters goodbye think it's
also it's kind of like that the Tiger
Woods and Tom Brady golf thing we're so
hungry for live TV and for live sports
we're like alright I'll watch this it's
you know it's a came out in 2008 we just
like very cool no it was certainly a
perfect storm of why it got so big yeah
100% cuz like stairs is better the going
clear docks better the Nirvana one of
Kurt Cobain HBO's better right now any
Tiger King was pretty good you have to
you have to care about Tigers well
you've been going clear it's like you
you know that's a decent one who took
Johnnie's a creepy one about human
trafficking that's wild uh they can
murder make you murder is great the
keepers was good on Netflix keepers is
good but yeah Murder two was a waste of
your [ __ ] life yeah so lame well it's
also like he did it he do indeed
represent self as the lawyer yeah we
know he did it his attorney looks guilty
this [ __ ] they all drive her these
people live in a level from Donkey Kong
Country they just drive around in mine
carts and [ __ ] each other there dude
they're guilty enough and I said stop
trying to spring this guy who's clearly
a monster what's funny is I remember
that came out I kind of defend him as
like we may get him out and then people
from that county when I dude it's all
the Netflix marketing propaganda this
dude's so guilty thing the fun he's dude
unless we know he's guilty of like other
things yes
sick raped people he's a bad
add dude what else you got right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]